about knowing that the will is outside
of you at least i think it my own will
is not in my body it's a result of the
collective will of conscience or
whatever it is the earth the humans the
animals all of it but what what do you
mean you said people don't want to
believe that they don't want to believe
that they're wet robots that there's
like meat sacks with electricity i think
they do i think some people do because i
mean it removes consequence from your
actions but child that's not what people
truly desire well they don't act that
way it's just a cop-out for when they
don't want to
take responsibility i don't i don't
agree i think you guys are projecting
tell me more well
are you religious at all yeah i'm a
christian oh okay and you marry as well
yeah i'm a catholic so
uh your view in your mind is is
like i think you're saying these people
certainly could not truly believe this
why would they want to feel that way
no no i mean i i know many of these
people we had someone on the show who
was like i'm nothing but a wet robot
nothing matters yeah i think sam harris
totally believes it
but i think that a lot of the people who
adopt that worldview are not totally
bought into it and that it's just sort
of an easy way for them to not confront
personal responsibility sure sure sure i
agree with that like atheism isn't on
the rise as far as i know it's just a
religiosity that's on the rise
nobody is dogmatic
these days about
being a
an electrified meat sack like i don't
think people feel strongly and are are
animated by that belief i think they're
the exception not the rule like there's
a hand there's a handful you know the
amazing atheist in those types yeah i
think uh
i agree with you
but i think it's be it's it's you you
don't need to be
uh a zealous atheist going door to door
and preaching the word of why there's no
god to live in a world with no moral
framework and believing your will be
done so i i'll put it this way a
tendency among people who believe in a
higher power is the higher power has a
will over them and tendency among people
who don't believe in higher power they
believe that their will be done yeah or
or a tendency towards which is an
interesting paradox because a lot of the
people who believe that their meat
robots don't believe in free will
that's true that's a strange it's a
strange paradox to live with yeah maybe
they're i don't know you know i was
thinking about this earlier and i'm not
uh
like i don't believe in any dogmatic
theistic religion i do believe in god i
do believe that there is something
greater and beyond us be it simulation
theory or just some purpose to the
universe
because i was thinking about
you know i was playing a video game and
in the video game you can choose to just
die i was playing spelunky every place
belong to you guys know spelunky oh i
know splunky is amazing spelunky too
it's a great game and uh it's a
roguelike game this is a game where
you play you collect items you try to
make it to the end and if you die you
just start over and it's a procedurally
generated world that's always different
and i thought to myself in this game
that i am playing
i've come to points where i felt like
i just didn't have enough items or ropes
or i didn't have the jet pack and i'm
like meh and i just jump my guy into
spikes then the game starts over and i
try again there was no consequence to
ending my character's life right but
here in this world there there's a
massive consequence to doing it and then
i thought about that i was like that
makes me feel like there is a greater
purpose and there is something that
matters to this universe beyond me it is
not just about me and being like well
you know my life wasn't good enough i'm
gonna jump on this fight and no that'd
be terrible you'd have a massive wave of
negative consequences for everyone
around you those who depend upon depend
on you and rely on you and then i'm like
so they're just as easily to me
something outside of me that matters
that
my will is not the most important will
in existence right but i feel like
people who don't see that are just like
i get what i want and that's all that
matters yeah and that's why you see
people like in my opinion leah thomas
the uh the swimmer in the ncaa recently
banned i guess they're now banning leah
thomas from swimming and this is a
person who has everyone saying we don't
want you a part of our event or i
shouldn't say everybody but a lot of
people expressing that and being like
don't care i'm happy
and i'm like it's interesting
if it if if it were me and i went to a
skateboarding contest
and let's say it was a a flip trick
contest for which i'm particularly good
and they were like bro we can't hang
with you we'd prefer if you didn't
compete because you're just going to win
i'd be like okay no problem i probably
wouldn't when i'm just saying if that
was if that was the instance where i was
like you're too good at this it wouldn't
be fair to everybody else i'd be like
all right i'm out i get it
but imagine being like no i'm better and
i deserve it i'm going to come in here
and everyone has to watch me like i just
aren't you like weirded out by that at
all like doesn't that make you feel bad
that's why so it's why as a libertarian
like i really stress individualism i
think it's so important
but what we also need to stress with
that is personal responsibility because
individualism just runs rampant without
any any insight or
but responsibility to other people you
know not just
like yourself right yeah that's where
you lose me with with individualism
because you don't have personal
responsibility without connection to
other people but you should
as an individual i'm an individual i
control everything that i do
but i'm not
such a freak that i don't want to have
other friends and think about how my
actions
affect other people and the people that
i'm close to and they as responsible
individuals should feel the same way and
so i do believe that there is a strong
sense of connection to other human
beings through that it's through
personal responsibility and caring and
also understanding that every human
value has some sort of you know unique
intrinsic value to it and sure some
people are more valuable than others
depending on how they contribute to the
world and what they do to you but i
would say that we're all born you know
screaming and naked into this world with
still some little bit of intrinsic
unique value
i wonder where that comes from you know
because i i i was raised christian
catholic and i certainly feel like
i don't know if if there is going to be
judgment or if it's just karma but it
certainly feels like what you do matters
yes and that there's
i don't know man
because even the weight of the question
like why do we feel like what we do
matters yeah but there's a reason we
feel that way it does at least like even
if it's not true you're not particularly
religious radiant no not but i don't
follow but what about karma
i think it's definitely real i was just
studying um
the phantom dna experiment last night
they bombard they take dna they put it
in a vacuum and they bombard it with a
photons and then they remove the dna
from the vacuum and the photons stay
there for like two weeks as if the dna
is still there like what's a ghost well
it's probably like d it's probably like
photons that are still orbiting a
something that used to be there that
doesn't know it's still behaving
feeling even maybe like when you look at
these clouds of plasma and the way they
move i mean maybe they're not
intelligent but they
definitely seem to be reacting to
stimuli so so that i get you you're
you're uh alluding to some kind of
spiritual after image your energy but
your magnetic field karma
i think it exists within the magnetic
fields behavior you but you but there's
like how does how is that how is that
your program i understand if you if you
if you do something mean to someone how
does something bad happen to you after
the fact you're programming your field
or the field around you with that
behavior and then that behavior is gonna
encourage you to continue with this
programming so you're saying like your
intentions and actions emit an energy
that has a reciprocal effect back yeah i
don't know if emitted energy is exactly
the right word they seem to be spinning
the reality in a way that becomes
addictive conducive leaves the truth all
right yeah that's why it's easier to do
the same thing over and over again i
noticed that in my in my baseline i feel
like it would take a long time to break
down point by point like how you see it
happening but i think the simple answer
is you believe that there is something
that happens outside of your actions
that will have like your actions will
have an impact they matter but i think
it's the way you feel about your actions
i just think about george bush uh junior
war in iraq like oh well bad karma he
took us into the war he's gonna have
background but he felt fine about it as
far as i could tell so i think it's if
you feel good about doing evil you're
gonna have good karma if you feel bad
about doing good you're gonna have bad
karma that's interesting
because so i'm trying to compare that to
how i feel about
kind of something you touched on earlier
which is when you do something bad and
then you do it again
and
i don't know i don't know if i agree
with you on that because i kind of feel
like the way i've often described it is
serving serving uh organization and and
order
is
typically good and serving chaos and
destruction is typically bad but not
always but tendency towards kind of like
a yin yang kind of thing and so i i kind
of view the world like
i i don't i don't know maybe like i was
saying maybe it's because i was raised
christian but i feel
that if i wrong other people i will
regret it like so there's a badness to
it that will affect you in some way i
don't believe in hell i don't think i'm
gonna be surrounded by ice or fire or be
chewed in the mouth of the devil himself
or anything like that
but i just kind of feel like
i don't know man it just feels like when
all this comes done they're going to be
like you are a dick i think everyone
knows it a good person to ask is a
soldier that killed in combat because if
you're killing for the greater good for
your country you have good karma
i hope that good karma comes to you for
doing that i don't know but in when
they're judged their soul is judged i
don't know maybe god will be like well
you evil yeah i think you killed
therefore but i don't think killing is
but there are so many factors that
go into evaluating an action like that
there's what the person thinks it was
just following whether or not it was
true
truly what they did
that that's their intent and then
there's the object of what they did
uh
which
some people would argue as murder but
others would argue as defending your
country yeah because you could think you
did it and have the karma and then
there's the consequence like maybe you
thought you killed someone but you
didn't
or a simulation in your mind or
something no like reverse some weird
mind a card crash happens and you think
it was your fault yeah yeah if you just
mistook your action for some other
action well how does that relate to
karma if you feel guilty about something
that wasn't technically your fault you
might i just mean there are many factors
that go into
evaluating whether an action was good it
was virtuous or sources rap it all
backward i guess what i was trying to
say is that i find a tendency among many
of these leftists is that
they don't have that fear correct they
do not fear that their actions there
will be any negative repercussions to
them that they can do what they please
and it is what it is and it doesn't
matter it's a bit paralyzing to worry
like i used to get into jainism a little
bit this religion where like you don't
even step on grass because it's too
destructive like destroy nothing leave
no trace and i'm like i can't that is
too it's too at some point you just
gotta get down with being destructive
because it's a huge part of what we are
we eat we kill and eat we destroy to
consume you know i mean i can i can tell
you about that as someone who was vegan
for 15 years um part of it is
neuroticism
i was i i abhorred violence i think i
was
uh i was
i was strangely violent as a as a female
child i think i was very violent i grew
up in a very conservative home whatever
you know i was the only girl in the
neighborhood
and i had sort of a reaction to my own
violent behavior and i was very
committed to non-violence but it did get
to a point for me with crohn's disease
where i had to make a literal life and
death decision and i had to get over my
neuroses and change my diet because i
could eat nothing else
and that's
i think a lot of environmentalists and
jainists and people like that have that
incredible
uh guilt associated with it and paranoia
and neuroses which is interesting
with the implications that tim raised of
basically kind of it's almost like they
don't have a conscience in these certain
respects because a lot of them also
behave in this very um compartmentalized
non-violent way towards animals and
environmentalism but it almost makes me
think maybe some of it is self-hate
hatred and self-loathing
i think it's i want to be careful too
because i don't think it's absolute when
i say like leftist i'm not trying to say
like literally every person on the left
thinks this i just say there's a
tendency towards yeah i certainly think
um
you've got people who claim to be
conservative religious or just really
bad people of course yeah but i think
you know typically what i what i'm
referring to in this is not the fringes
it's the the mainstream among the
mainstream a step like mainstream and
establishment left
i question the morality of these
personalities who don't seem to have one
yes when they'll say stop and frisk is
bad red flag laws are good
yes it's
why is stop and frisk bad well because
they they directed it at black people do
you think they're not going to do that
with red flag laws
i tweeted i'll tell you this i tweeted
this earlier i said
trans people are are
have higher suicide rates and the left
has a higher uh tendency towards mental
illness
red flag laws by that logic will
disproportionately affect the left yes
and um
the tennis player marina
lavatorova how do you pronounce her name
yeah something like that tweeted at me
some really nasty thing and she was just
like
you know do you do were you are you
naturally an [ __ ] or you have to did
you have to try really hard where did
you come up with this bs statistic the
left mental illness i know where you and
pa voter fraud which is weird i didn't
tweet about and then she was like i know
where the real mental illness is it's in
this delusion and it was like this
really nasty thing and i was just like
okay went on google typed in liberal
mental illness and then just started
screen grabbing all of the things that
came up because they do
she ended up taking the tweet down and
saying i apologize but that's the
example
high profile prominent individuals who
are angry arrogant and use their
ignorance for influence or they use
their ignorance in their ignorance they
influence
not even an effort to google search it
hubris and laziness yes and that is
driving one
fact one a large portion of the
political debate thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you